[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه اخبار الظهيره
مشاهدينا
تسريبات لمسؤولين ايرانيين تكشف قلق
النظام من الاحتجاجات ومخاوف من ارهاق
قوات الامن
برلمان وفرنس للتظاهرات وتصويت امامي
مرتقب لاستبعاد طهران من هيئه المراه
والقوات الاسرائيليه تقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
في مواجهات في رام الله والخليل
مواجهه المرتقبه بين امريكا وايران في
مباراه
تستقطب انظار السياسيين قبل الرياضيين
اذا المشاهدين نبدا من ايران حيث انتشرت
تسريبات تظهر قلقه مسؤولينا ايرانيين من
هزيمه النظام بالحرب الاعلاميه جراء قمع
قوات الامن للاحتجاجات طبعا هذه التسريبات
والتسريب الصوتي سجل تفاصيل اجتماع نائب
قائد البسيج قاسم قريش مع مسؤوليه وسائل
الاعلام طبعا الحكوميه خلال هذا الاجتماع
طلب احد قاده البسيج طالب الاعلام الرسمي
للنظام لضروره الاعلان عن انتهاء
الاحتجاجات ليرد عليه شخص اخر ساخر بان
الاحتجاجات لا زالت مستمره المسؤولون ايضا
تطرقوا خلال هذا الاجتماع الى ان
الاحتجاجات وصلت لاثنتين 62 جامعه وكليه
اضرب احد عشر منها عن الدراسه حديث
الحاضرين طلع ايضا مواقف المرشد الايراني
حيث قال في تسريبات ان خامنئي اشتكى خلال
لقاء مع احد المسؤولين من صمت اعضاء مجلس
تشخيص مصلحه النظام وعدم انتقادهم للم جين
بالتسريبات هناك اشاره ايضا الى اثنتي
عشره هجمه استهدفت مقر البسيج وايضا مكاتب
ممثلين مرشد ومكتب النائب عن مدينه سيسوار
في البرلمان الايراني هذه التسريبات كشفت
ايضا عن خطه البسيج للقيام باجراءات ضد
امام جمعه اهل السنه في زهدان ملاوي عبد
الحميد طبعا لتدمير مكانته بين الشعب هذه
التسريبات نقلت عن احد مسؤوليه البسيج
قوله في بدايه هذا الاجتماع انه سيتم
توزيعه 10,000 تذكره على موالين للنظام
للمشاركه في مونديال قطر وان هؤلاء
المشجعين يتم اسكانهم في جزيره تايش
ويتمون نقلهم الى قطر لمشاهده المباريات
قبل ان يعود مره اخرى تسريبات نقلت قوله
احد الاشخاص في الاجتماع ان هناك خمسه
الاف كاميرا في الملعب تسجل كل تحركات
معارضي النظام الايراني طبعا هذا بالنسبه
للتسريبات ما في ما يتعلق بالتصريحات
الرسميه فقد اعترف الجنرال الايراني امير
علي زاديه قائد القوات الجويه في الحرس
الثوري اعترف بمقتل اكثر من 300 شخص في
التظاهرات والاحتجاجات المستمره في مختلف
انحاء البلاد منذ شهرين طبعا هذه الحصيله
الرسميه تقل بكثير عن الحصيله التي
اعلنتها منظمه نشطاء حقوق الانسان في
ايران المنظمه تقول ان اربعه
451 محتجا و60 من القوات الامن قتلوا منذ
بدء الاضطرابات كما اعتقل اكثر من 18,000
شخص على كل المشاهدين المزيد معنا من لندن
الباحث في الشان الايراني وجدان عبد
الرحمن اهلا بك استاذ وجدان اسمح لي انا
ابدا بالتسريبات وقبل ان ندخل بتفاصيل ما
تم نشره اريد الحديث عن قضيه التسريب
بصوره عامه من هو المستهدف بهذا الاطار
ومن المستفيد
تحياتي لك يا استاذه ميسون والمتابعينك
الكرام هذه
التسريبات اولا نحن نعرف تماما بانه مؤخرا
دخلت الكثير من الاطراف للحصول على
معلومات من خلال
الهاكر تهكير المواقع ان كانت الاخباريه
للنظام الايراني او بعض المواقع الحساسه
لنظام وتسربت الكثير من هذه
المعلومات بكل تاكيد ما سمعناه من همم
خلال هذه همم الاجتماع
يشير بانه بالفعل النظام الايراني بدا
يواجه مشكله حقيقيه وكما اشرته بالخبر انه
حتى موضوع مجلس اااه
مجلس تشخيص مصلحه النظام لم يبدا اهتماما
او تعاونا او تعاطفا مع بيت المرشد وهذا
يشير الى الخلافات الداخليه في البيت
النظام نفسه اما
المستفيد من هذه التسريبات لا شيء كانها
هذه التسريبات تدعم الحراج
يعرفون كيف يمكن التعامل مع همم مواجهه
هذا النظام وخاصه بعد هذه التسريبات التي
بين القوات الامنيه همم
كما ذكرت نوع من الانشقاق ت بس هو اول
المواقف المختلفه تعكس هذه التسريبات ولكن
ايضا في ما يتعلق بالتعتيم الاعلامي هل هو
امر طبيعي ام انه فيه جديد وماذا عن من
اجاب انه كيف لنا ان نتحدث عن انتهاء
الاحتجاجات وهي مستمره هل في نوع من
الرفض اذا ما صحه تعبير للتعاطي مع هذه
الروايه الحكوميه او لا
بكل تاكيد
الاعتقالات التي
الصحفيين ان كان الصحفيين الرياضيين او
الصحفيين العاملين في بعض القنوات الرسميه
والغير الرسميه هذه يشير بانه موضوع
التعتيم اعلامي هو احد هذه القضايا لان
يعتبرون بان موضوع الحديث عن موضوع
الاحتجاجات همم
شرارتها بشكل اكبر وان تتوسع ولهذا قاموا
بخرع كبير
الصحفيين
واعلامي لذلك هذه التصريحات تشير بانه
بالفعل انه دور الاعلام يلعب دورا كبيرا
خاصه بعد همم اعلام الغربي الذي بدا يتوجه
ضد النظام الايراني واضر بشكل كبير لان
ليس فقط
على المستوى السياسي بهذا الاطار سات ربما
ويمكن للاشاره الى تبني البرلمان الفرنسي
بالاجماع قرار لدعم الشعب الايراني يدين
خصوصا تقييد الحريات وايضا حقوق المراه
طبعا القرار دانا باشد العبارات ما سماه
بالقمع الوحشي والمعمم الممارس ضد
المتظاهرين كما اكد دعمه للشعب الايراني
في تطلعه الى الديمقراطيه طبعا هاي
بالنسبه الى دانا الادانه الفرنسيه هناك
ايضا تصويت مرت قبل المجلس الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي التابع للامم المتحده منتصف
شهر ديسمبر المقبل على مشروع قرار امريكي
لاستبعاد ايران من هيئه الامم المتحده
المعنيه بالمساواه بين الجنسين وايضا فيما
يتعلق طبعا بتمكين المراه مشروع القرار
الامريكي يهدف لمعاقبه ايران بسبب حرمانها
النساء من حقوقهن وقمعها الوحشي
للاحتجاجات اشاره مسؤول امم خلال تصريحات
لوكاله رويترز ان الولايات المتحده على
وشك حشد الدعم اللازم لاخراج ايران من
الهيئه الامميه اعود اليك سيد وجدان
الحديث عن هذه التحركات الغربيه نبدا
بالايدين الفرنسيه ونمر على اخراج ايران
من هذه المظله الامميه هل هناك توجه
للطاعات الان مع ايران كما تم مع روسيا
فيما يتعلق بتواجدها اينما كان على
المستوى الدولي
فيما يتعلق بموضوع روسيا ويمكن اا ان تصل
الى ايران بكل تاكيد لانها ما نشهده اليوم
التحرك القاضي هو تحرك حقيقي اتجاه النظام
الايراني وهذا همم ما شاهدناه بسبب
النتائج التي شاهدناها قبل ايام فيما
يتعلق بموضوع مجلس حقوق الانسان والاذان
التي همم
ادانت ان النظام الايراني باقام حقوق
الانسان همم خاصه همم الدول التي وقعت على
اذان
شهاده هنالك مزيد من هذه الدول انت همم
فرنسا فيما يتعلق في موضوع ادانت النظام
الايراني ما شاهدناه في هذه الفتره ساده
ميسون يختلف تماما عن الاحتجاجات السابقه
شاهدنا في 2019 قتل اكثر من 1500 لكن
الدول الغربيه لم تاخذ هذا القرارات
ما عليه اخذت الدول هذا القرار تم اقصاء
ايران او لم يتم هل النظام الايراني معني
وان لم يكن معنا على ماذا يعول
فقط على موضوع اقمار
قمع الاحتجاجات في الداخل والاستخدام
السلاح لكن القرارات الاوروبيه ازداد
ميسون مهمه جدا خاصه في هذه الفتره لاننا
دخلت هنالك الكثير من الملفات التي همم
منها ملف انه الايراني في الحرب الروسيه
وهذه تعتبر خطوط حمراء للدول الغربيه لذلك
نشات هذا الحراج همم الغربي بشكل مكثف ضد
النظام الايراني
وجدان عبد الرحمن شكرا لكم مباشره الى
الرومان يبدو ان هناك اجتماع طبعا في بخار
سلاح النت ولكن سنحاول نقل على الاقل بعض
الصور التي تاتينا من هناك لهذا الاجتماع
تويكس انترنت
وورك
نلتقي فيه
مجلس اوروبا
[موسيقى]
انا
لسه
مهم وهذا ما يجب ان يشارك فيه روسيا
الا ان الحوار المؤسسي
[موسيقى]
متعلق
روسيا وهذه الحوارات الجاريه حاليا قبل ان
ناخذ السؤال التالي
استراتيجيه كما كما اتفق عليه في قمه
مدريد هذا الصيف هل يمكن ان يكون هناك
استراتيجيه بوجود ثلاث دول واثنين من شركه
النيته هل يمكن ان تعالج هذه القضيه نعم
البحر الاسود هو ذو اهميه كبيره
وكذلك همم الدول لثلاث تركيا
فورت نايت
2014 زدنا وجودنا في منطقه البحر الاسود
ونعمل عن كتب مع اثنتين من الدول
البحر الاسود وهذا قمنا به قبل الحرب
وانواصلها حتى الان نعم هذه المنطقه تتطلب
منها
يواجه كل التحديات في المنطقه
وهذا همم
هذه
التحالف في مواجهه هذه القضيه
لانها لديها اكبر حدود بريه مع اوكرانيا
السريع للنشر السريع لقوه نيته
فهناك دبابات فرنسيه
تحركت
وشاهدنا ذلك
اذا كان لها دور مهم جدا في
الدعم لاوكرانيا
اكبر حدود بريه مع اوكرانيا
الروماني لاوكرانيا مهم جدا من دعم
الانساني وغيره
وايضا
نقدر المساعده الرومانيه
والرساله ستكون واضحه بان علينا ان نحافظ
على هذا الدم
وخاصه انظمه الدفاع الجوي لمساعده همم
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها جوا وبرا وبحرا
بالطبع كما تعلمون فان رومانيا تستضيف عدد
كبير من اللاجئين
همم من عبروا الحدود
ايه وذهبوا الى دول مختلفه في اوروبا وهذه
مساله مهمه تبين
الدعم الساخي لاوكرانيا ولا الاوكرانيين
الذين اضطروا لمغادره بلادهم علينا ان
نتفهم انه عندما حدث الغزو نيته لم تفاجا
بل كنا
نعدل مثل هذا العدوان 2014
طيب الدفاعات اثنين بالمئه من رومانيا
وبغيرها من الحلفاء
لدينا معلومات
استخباراتيه قبل ذلك باشهر منذ خريف 21
العام الماضي بنعرف ان روسيا تنويه غزوه
اوكرانيا
تحرك الروسي
التحرك الروسي همم زدنا وجودنا في المنطقه
دهنوي»
وعندما بدا
الغزو منذ صبيحه ذلك اليوم
قررنا بالتحرك الدفاعي وزياده وجدنا لم
نكن غير مستعدين ابدا
2014 حتى 2022 لم نفاجئ بل تصرفنا خلال
تلك الفتره لزياده وجودنا واستعدادنا
وجاهزاتنا وكثير من الحلفاء فرنسا
اخر تفضل
سؤال من الوكاله البولنديه شكرا لك سيدي
لدي سؤالين من اولهما حول
علاقات
علاقته اوكرانيا
ومساله عضويتها
لانه في 2018 كان هناك اتفاق وانا
اوكرانيا ستكون احد الاعضاء ومن ثم
طلب ان يكونوا جزء من هذا التحالف اين نحن
من هذه العمليه وكيف تعرف العلاقه بينكم
بين تحالف واكرهانيا
سريع وكذلك الولايات المتحده كحاليل ايضا
ماذا نتوقع
من بحثا بهذه القضيه في المستقبل
مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وغير من الدول الذين
يقدمون المساعداتي لاوكرانيا
تحالف بقياده الامريكيه
وايضا هناك جهد عالمي لدعم اخرى مشاهدينا
سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لطبعا الامين العام لحلفه
وبينما حلف الناتو طبعا يجتمع مشاهدينا في
بخارست ايضا في بروكسل مراسل العربيه اثبت
بان لجنه الدفاع والامن في البرلمان
الاوروبي ستعقد هذا اليوم سلسله اجتماعات
بشان قوه التدخل السريع الاوروبيه التي
تقرر انشاؤها كي تكون جاهزه للتدخل بحلول
20 25 مراسل العربيه ايضا اضاف ان
الاجتماع سيناقش فهم سياسه روسيا النوويه
وسياسات تصدير الاسلحه في ضوء حرب اوكراني
على كلن للمزيد حول هذه الاجتماعات معنا
من بروكسل مراسل العربيه نور الدين
الفريدي اهلا بك نور الدين اهم العناوين
الرئيسيه في هذه الاجتماعات اتفضل
العناوين الاوروبيه اليوم ذات الصله بحربي
اوكرانيا ميسونيا التعبئه في صفوف الدول
الاتحاد الاوروبي وايضا مثل ما شاهدنا في
على مستوى حلف شمال الاطلسي لتزويد
اوكرانيا في هذه المرحله بالذات بمحولات
الكهرباء بالوقود بكل العده اللازمه
لمواجهه برد الشتاء لان الدول الاوروبيه
ودولنات ايضا تعتبر ان روسيا تستهدف بشكل
متعمد البنا التحتيه مثل محطات الطاقه من
اجل ان تكون اوكرانيا رهينه البردي
والظلام حسب كلام المسؤولين الرسميين همم
الدول الاوروبيه سواء كان اجتماعات
الجاريه اليوم او امس تعتبر ان استهداف
المؤسسات والمحطات النوويه والبناء
التحتيه عفوا البناء التحتيه المدنيه همم
ترقى الى همم جرائم الحرب هناك نقاشات
عديده على مستويات على مستوى الخبراء او
على مستوى رسمي همم ميسون هنا في بروكسل
حول ان المحكمه الدوليه حول اوكرانيا
ونقاشات تتجاه نحو خيارين اثنين الخيار
الاول هو ان تتفق اوكرانيا مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي مع مجلس اوروبا لانشاء تحالف
ومحكمه دوليه تستند الى قوانين اوكرانيا
والقانون الدولي والخيار الثاني ربما انه
في منتصف الشهر المقبل سيقدم الاتحاد
الاوروبي مشروعا الى الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده من اجل التصويت على انشاء محكمه
دوليه حول اوكرانيا النقاشات ستزال
متواصله همم معقده للغايه من ناحيه
القانونيه خاصه ثم يتعلق بجوارب صلاحيات
التي نقاشات ربما العنوان الثالث الاخير
وبسرعه هو فشل الدول الاوروبيه على مستوى
الاتحاد كل الدول والعشرين حول ايجاد
تحديدي سقفي همم سعره نفطي الروسي المورد
من الموالانه الخلاف يدور حول السعر الذي
حددته مجموعه السبع بين 60 70 همم دولار
من الخام بينما بولندا ودول البطيخ تريده
خف هذا السقف الى مستوى 30 دولار للبرميل
والنقاشات متوفي ولكن
الخلافات كبيره ومتسعه بين الجانبين
مراسل العربيه نور الدين الفريدي شكرا
جزيلا لك
في اخبار الظهيره ولكن بعد قليل رئيس
البرلمان الليبيه يتحدث عن اللقاءات هامه
بالقاهره واجتماع مرتقب مع خالد يوسف
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره ونكمل
من القاهره ومن هناك اعلن رئيس البرلمان
الليبي عقيل الصالحه قبل لقاء اجراه مع
الامين العام للجامعه العربيه احمد ابو
الغيث ان لقاءات هامه ستشهدها القاهره في
الساعات القادمه من ابرزها اجتماعهم مع
المبعوث الاممي الى ليبيا طبعا بالاضافه
الى رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد
المشري دانا
المتحده غدا
وايضا
يقنعه بذوره الاسراء في حال
الازمه الليبيه الجميع يدعو للانتخابات
لكن الانتخابات تريد بيئه وتجهيز عمليه
الانتخابات
تعلمون جميعا ان ليبيا يوجد بها اعلام
السوري
بعت فيها نجاح ثوره 17 فبراير هناك اعلان
للسوري على اساس الاعلان الدستوريه
منتخب مجلس النواب انتخبت اللجنه وضع
الدستور اذا هناك قاعده دستوريه قائمه
هناك مشروع جديد لدستور دائما هو المعروض
الان نتمنى نتمم التوافق عليه مجلس الدوله
جسمي استشاري ولم يكون غرفه في السلطه
يعتقد ان مجلس الدوله
نوال المزيد ينضم الينا من القاهره فتحي
المريمي المستشار الاعلامي لرئاسه مجلس
النواب الليبي اهلا بك استاذ فتحي واسمحلي
ان ابدا بما اييه وصفوا طبعا عقيله صالح
بوصفها بالاجتماعات الهامه تفاصيل ما يمكن
لنا ان نتوقع وتفاصيل ما هو مقرر بحث في
هذه الاجتماعات ونبدا مع المبعوث الاميه
من القاهره نعم فخامه رئيس مجلس النواب
صرح بانه ستكون هناك اجتماعات هامه طبعا
اهم هذه الاجتماعات هو لقائي امس مع
الامين العام لجامعه الدول العربيه وكان
اجتماعي مهم جدا تم عرض العديد من
الموضوعات
الهامه في همم وضع همم ليبيا همم من حيث
العديد من القضايا واا
بان الجامعه العربيه
يتم طرحه والمواضيع العالقه الان والتي
يمكن تجاوزها من خلال هذه المحادثه
هي طبعا اولها بالدرجه الاولى
الاشراع بعمليه الانتقام سواء في الرئاسه
او في مجلس النواب هذا بالدرجه الاولى
لابد علينا نحن كعطراف ليبيه جميعا يعني
مجلس نواب مجلس اهل الدوله وكذلك باقي
الاطراف الاخرى في ليبيا عليها ان تسرع في
عمليه اجراء الانتخابات في ليبيا وذلك هو
في قاعده دستوريه متفق عليها وايضا حتى
توحيد المؤسسات والسلطه التنفيذيه ذلك
يعني لابد من اعانه جامعه الدول العربيه
وباحثه الامم المتحده وكل الاطراف التي
لديها مصالح اا في ليبيا عليها ان تعين
ليبيا في ذلك على سبيل المثال همم مجلس
النواب الفتره السابقه
انتخب رئيس للحكومه رئيس الحكومه قام
بتشكيل حكومته هذه نعتبرها نحن في مجلس
النواب هي الحكومه الرسميه لانها منطلقه
من مجلس النواب همم بعض الدول مش بعض
الدول يعني تستطيع يقول كل الدول حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تتعامل معها وتتعامل مع حكومه
منتهيه الولايه وهي حكومه
عن اهميه الانتخابات يتم فرز المرشحين
فيها فيما يتعلق بالمناصب السياديه وكيف
يمكن لها ان تتحرك على الارض يعني عم نحكي
عن حكمتين صراحه نتحدث عن
انقسام افقي موجود فيما يتعلق بالمناصب
السياديه
طبعا مهمه جدا لان هي بالدرجه الاولى
لمجلس النواب صور رقبيه منها او الماليه
او غيرها همم من اجل النقطه خطوات يعني
سريعه في اتجاه العمليه الانتخابيه لابد
من توحيد هذه المؤسسات لانها بتدرجه
الاولى رقبيه وكذلك المركزي وهو مالي همم
طبعا لا بد من تنفيذ ذلك على امر الواقع
كما تفضلت في ذلك ياتي بان المجلس الاعلى
للدوله لديه ملفات واسماء محاله من مجلس
النواب لديه من دعاء حتى هذه اللحظه لم
يحيلها يعني مطالب بالاشراع في عمليه في
حاله الاسنان وهو عن كل منصب ثلاثه اسماء
ومجلس النواب يختار احد هذه
التطبيق بالنهايه من القاهره فتحي عبد
الكريم المريمي طبعا المستشار الاعلامي
لرئاسه مجلس النواب الليبي شكرا جزيلا لك
قتلت القوات الاسرائيليه شقيقين فلسطينيين
في مواجهات في بلده كفرعين شمال رام الله
بالضفه الغربيه كما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه عن مقتل شاب اخر برصاص الجيش
الاسرائيلي في بلده شمال الخليل كما اصيب
احد عشر اخرين في المواجهات مع الجيش
الاسرائيلي في البلده ثمانيه منهم بالرصاص
الحي وفقه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بمولدات كهربائيه ل تعويض النقص الحاصل في
شبكتها امام تجمع سبعه من وزراء خارجيه
الدول الشمال الاوروبي ودول البلطيق شدد
وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيين دي مترو كوليبا
شدد على ان بلاده بحاجه الى محولات
كهربائيه فضلا عن دفاع جويه
ضربات الجويه الروسيه على البنا التحتيه
للطاقه وفي هذا الايطار بالنسبه للرد
الامريكي افاده مسؤولون امريكي
راينا جزءا منه اليوم جزءا منه عن مساعده
ماليه كبيره لتخفيف من منطقه الاضرار التي
سببها القذف الروسي لشبكه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه مسؤول كبير في الاداره
الامريكيه قال ان هذه المساعده التي يعلن
عنها تفصيل طبعا في هذا اليوم وزير
الخارجيه انتون بلينكن سيعلنها ستكون
كبيره وهذه ليست النهايه بحسب طبعا
التصريحات في نشره الظهيره واخبار الظهيره
ولكن بعد قليل
محكمه الارهاب في تونس توجهه لزعيم حركه
النهضه راشد الغنوشي تهمه تصدير الارهاب
متابعه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى اخبار الظهيره افاده
مراسل العربيه بان محكمه الارهاب في تونس
اخلت سبيل رئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي
بعد تحقيق استمر لمده ثنتين 10 ساعه بتهمه
التسفير لبؤر التوتر المراسل قال ان
الغنوشي اقر في كلمه طبعا بعد اخلاء سبيلي
بان المحكمه وجهت له تهمه التسفير لبؤر
التوتر واصفا بانها تهدف للاقصاء السياسيه
ونبقى مشاهدينا في المباريات وتحديدا نسلط
الضوء على المباراه المرتقبه بين ايران
والولايات المتحده طبعا ضمن كاس العالم
لكره القدم حيث اعاده الى الاذهان ذكريات
مونديال 98 بمشاهد الاحترام المتبادل بين
لاعبي الباردين
سياسيا موعد مختلفه حضرت فيها السياسه
بقوه في ملاعب الرياضه
[موسيقى]
المزيد ينضم الينا من عمان المحلل الرياضي
خالد الخطاب اهلا بك استاذ خالد اسمح لي
ان ارى رؤيتك لطبيعه هذا اللقاء ما بين
ايران والولايات المتحده ان كان فعلا
السياسه ستطغى على الفريقين وميزاج
المراقب
متابع لهذه المباريات كيف ينظر الى
المنتخب الايراني
لمنتخب دون غيره سياسه بمعنى اخر اما ميل
للتضامن مع ما يحدث في ايران او ربما عداء
لما يحدث في بعض الدول وتدخلات في الدول
العربيه
نعم استاذ صباح الخير صباح الخير لاستاد
المشاهدين نعم مباراه ايران والولايات
المتحده فعلا هي مباراه سياسيه بامتياز
مباراه مهمه في كلتا الحالتين السياسه
وامور فنيه وتاهل على الصعيد الفني هي
مباراه مهم للمنتخب الايراني لبلوغ
الدور ثمن النهائي وايضا هي كذلك للولايات
المتحده لكن هذه المباراه تاخذ طابع سياسي
اكثر وهذه مختلفه عن مونديال 1998 لما كان
في يمكن همم تقريبا علاقه طيبه باللاعبين
او كما ظهر لكن الان هذه المباراه مختلفه
خاصه انه للمنتخب الامريكي غرد على تويتر
امس ووضع علم ايران بدون ااه شعار جمهوريه
الاسلاميه وهذه رساله دعم للمحتجين من هذه
الخطوه بنشوف قديش هذه المباراه راح تكون
فيها احتقان ايضا على الجانب الاخر
المنتخب الايراني هذا مخالف للقوانين
الرياضيه ليست كذلك
الان اصبحت الرياضه ممكن توصل فيها رسائل
سياسيه اكثر طبعا هو اكيد مخالف الان لكن
يمكن السياسه بتضغط على الامور الرياضيه
خاصه في العلاقات المتوتره بين ايران
والولايات المتحده ايضا الوضع مختلف
بالنسبه لايران ايران في المونديال 1998
يمكن يشوفهم كانوا على قلب رجل واحد لكن
اللاعبين في ظل التصاعد وتيره الاحتجاجات
في ايران ممكن تكون هذه فرصه للاعبين
المنتخب الايراني او البعض منهم انه يوصل
رسائل انه هو دعم همم دعم للاحتجاجات ومع
المتظاهرين ممكن ايضا نشوف لاعبين مع
النظام ومع القبضه الامنيه اللي بيفرضها
النظام الايراني
الموقف كان واحد بالنسبه للمنتخب عندما تم
عرض النشيد الوطني همم الايراني
والكل في ما بدا بانه متضامن مع الداخل
الايراني والاحتجاجات
هو بشكل بشكل رسمي التضامن اكيد يعني
اللاعبين المنتخب راح يظهر بهذا الشكل لكن
يمكن ممكن تداعيات الاحتجاجات وشوفنا
رساله ابنه شقيقه الخميني ممكن هذه تساعد
ايضا في يعني اثاره همم اشعال الثوره من
جديد ايضا ممكن نشوف انقسامات في الجمهور
الايراني يعني الجمهور الايراني نعم هو
راح يوقف خلف متخبه ضد الولايات المتحده
لكن ممكن تكون هذه فرصه للبعض لاعلان
تاييد للاحتجاجات الموجوده الان ونشوفها
في ايران فهي المباراه
الحاسمه بين الدولتين من عمان محلل
الرياضي خالد شكرا جزيلا لك
مشاهدينا هناك مخاوف امريكيه من ان تلحق
الصين بالولايات المتحده بل وتتفوق عليها
في مجال تكنولوجيا الفضاء العسكريه دعونا
متابعه
نحو الفضاء
على الصعود السياسيه والاقتصاديه
ان يسمى صراعا طرق اليوم الى مستوى اعلى
الى الفضاء
تطوير الاسلحه على الارض لم يعد كافيا بل
اصبح التكنولوجيا الفضاء العسكري مفتاح
المنافسه
هي المهمه الاخيره لاستكمال بناء محطه
الفضاء الصينيه لكنها احدى المهام
الفضائيه التي تتخوف منها الولايات
المتحده في ظل التغذيه المستمره والسريعه
التي توفرها الصين لتطوير قدرتها الفضائيه
لتصبح منافسا لا يستهان به في مجال هيمنت
عليه الولايات المتحده وروسيا لسنوات
اعتقد انه من الممكن ان يتمكنوا من اللحاق
بنا وتجاوزنا بالتاكيد التقدم الذي احرزه
كان مذهلا وسريعا
في الوقت الذي تتعاضم فيه مخاوف واشنطن من
التفوق الصيني سيكون استكمال بناء محطه
الفضاء الصينيه اشاره اخرى لامريكا حول
طموحات الصين المتزايده مع طرح احتمال
توقف محطه الفضاء الدوليه التابعه لناسا
الا ان المحللين يرون ان استمرار الرياده
الامريكيه في صناعه الفضاء تكمن في القطاع
الخاص المتنمي بشكل مستمر عكس ما هو الحال
عليه في الصين
جزر متنازع عليها في بحر الصين قد تصبح في
المستقبل نزاعا على القمر والمريخ وغيرهما
من الكواكب وثرواتها نظره بعيده للمستقبل
تدفع الدول لتخصيص ميزانيه ضخمه
للارتقاء بالقدرات الفضائيه العلميه
والعسكريه الى عمر العربيه الى العصفور
الازرق معارك تويتر لا تنتهي في اخر
فصولها هاجمها الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه الى
الناس شركه ابل بعد وقفها الاعلان في
تويتر طلبها بنشر اجراءات الرقابه لحمايه
عملائها قال ماسك في سلسله تغريدات على
تويتر قال ان ابل هددت بحجب تطبيق تويتر
من مجارها دون ابلاغهم بالاسباب بالتهمه
ماسك ابل باخذ ضريبه سريه بمقدار 30% من
مطوري التطبيقات عبر متجر حماس على
النشطاء في تويتر التصوير على نشر شركه
ابل الرقابه لديها الى العناوين
تسريبات لمسؤولين ايرانيين تكشف قلق
النظام من الاحتجاجات ومخاوف من ارهاق قوه
الامن
برلمان وفرنسا يدين قمع ايران للتظاهرات
وتصويت امم مرتقب لاستبعاد طهران من هيئه
المراه
القوات الاسرائيليه تقتل ثلاثه فلسطينيين
في مواجهات في رام الله والخليل
مواجهه المرتقبه بين امريكا وايران في
مباراه
سياسيين قبل الرياضيين
نلتقي غدا المشاهدين
[موسيقى]